this week's episode is brought to you in
part by after-the-fact a podcast from
the Pew Charitable Trusts 30 years why
does that number matter it's been more
than 30 years since a new type of
antibiotic has made it to market now I
bet you're wondering why a stat is only
the beginning of the story to understand
the numbers shaping society's biggest
challenges listen to after the fact a
podcast from the Pew Charitable Trusts
available on stitcher and anywhere else
you get your podcast visit putress org
slash science mag to learn more this
week's episode is also brought to you in
part by Kiwi Co Huey co-creates super
cool hands-on projects for kids of all
ages that make it fun to learn about
science engineering technology art and
math inspire creative confidence this
year with Kiwi Co Q eco is offering
science magazine podcast listeners the
chance to try them for free to redeem
this offer and learn more visit kiwi
koat.com slash magazine
welcome to the science podcast for
February 8 2019 I'm Sara Crespi in this
week's show I talk with staff writer
Eric stocks Ted about bringing the
potato into the 21st century this
delicious and very complex tuber may
face some trouble when it comes to
climate change and Megan Cantwell and
Bob service discuss a pill that gives
you an injection once it settles on the
bottom of your stomach and flips over
like a little turtle what could possibly
be wrong with potatoes are they not the
perfect food delicious weather fried
baked boiled mashed or salad staff
writer Eric stocks Ted wrote a feature
this week detailing all the planned
improvements for what I consider the
perfect tuber hi Eric hey Sarah what is
wrong with the potato what issues should
potato lovers be concerned about well
there's nothing wrong once it gets to
your plate ah but if you're a potato
farmer there are some long-standing
challenges and there are new challenges
arriving right well what are some of the
long-standing challenges of growing a
potato everybody's probably heard of the
Irish potato famine yeah late blight is
the disease that triggered a famine in
the mid 19th century in Ireland and
that's microbial pathogen that's been a
problem for potato growers ever since
that hasn't been solved the potato
blight no wasn't it not at all it is
probably the top problem for potato
growers anywhere and in the developing
world where you don't have fungicides
easily available it can lead to 15 30
percent loss of the potato harvest on
average of every year Wow is there
anything else that makes it hard to grow
potatoes in my mind you just stick a
piece of potato in the ground or one of
the eyes from the potato that grows a
plant and then underneath the ground off
of the plant you get tubers that you can
as potatoes potato does really well in
different soils and different lights but
one thing that potato doesn't like is a
hot night if the temperature gets too
warm a potato plant won't start to make
tubers and then you don't have a crop
that's one of the key problems as
climate change is happening many places
those temperatures at night are creeping
up and then they're all the other things
that farmers have to deal with frost or
hail storms right basically climate
change is increasing the severity of
weather and the unpredictability of bad
weather and both those things are bad
for any farmer and they're bad for
potato farmers when it comes to some of
the other staple crops rice wheat they
have gone through this Green Revolution
where they've been optimized and
improved through all these different
methods but that past potatoes by why is
that
a lot of those improvements the increase
in yields during the Green Revolution
that of course helped prevent famine a
lot of those improvements were due to
breeding in wheat for example one of the
key things that plant breeders did in
the 1940s and 50s was they shortened the
stock of the wheat plant that
improvement meant that each wheat plant
could bear more grain and it was far
less likely to bend over in bad weather
which would ruin but could could ruin
the crop those kinds of changes happened
in rice and in wheat and the yields went
up that didn't happen in potato why
didn't the potato get the same Green
Revolution treatment potatoes and we can
compare them with corn for example corn
has two copies of each chromosome and
potato has four copies of chromosomes
which makes it harder to improve the
potato gradually compared to corn it's
hard to tweak it and make it a little
better every generation having so many
copies of these chromosomes makes it
difficult because if you like a gene
that's present in a potato it might not
get passed down in enough of those
chromosomes in order to show up in the
spring in the progeny when you're
breeding one potato with another potato
in corn with two copies of the
chromosomes it's easier to predict
what's gonna happen in the next
generation if you've made a mistake you
can go back and make another cross and
you can gradually improve it now that's
really not possible with potato potato
breeders get one shot they take two
potatoes and they cross them they have
to grow a hundred thousand little potato
plants from that cross and evaluate all
of them now once they find one that they
like if they tried to cross it again
you'd get a whole new mixture of traits
it wouldn't you got to do a hundred
thousand again and you may not have the
things you liked preserve from the last
time you worked on it what that means
practically is that it takes a really
long time to breed a new variety of
potato it can take 15 years from your
first cross until you're ready to give
it to farmers and historically some of
these new potato varieties some of them
took decades to create and you can't
really improve on it like I said before
that means that if you make a really
great potato people just keep growing it
you know the russet Burbank it's yeah
it's the best potato for french fries
you know how old that potato is no it's
more than a hundred years old Sarah and
now it's still the dominant potato in
North America that's amazing but it
might not be as resilient as we want it
to be when climate changes so changing
it is going to be tough
what about genetic engineering can we
just stick a desireable gene into this
russet potato and and go on from there
there are some real advantages to using
genetic engineering let's take the rest
of Burbank if you wanted to make it
resist bruising you can take a single
gene you can make a single change and
not alter anything else about the plant
you can't do that with traditional
potato breeding okay so what's the
problem why aren't we just genetically
engineering all these desirable traits
into potatoes any of these
characteristics that are complicated
traits yield
that's a complicated trait and so
there's no single gene then you can
pluck out from somewhere else and put
into the variety you want right now
those traits are bred in the traditional
way slow patiently and eventually you
get there I think we really need to
address where these traits where this
variety is coming from you did mention
briefly that potatoes originated in the
Andes and there is an incredible amount
of diversity still in potatoes there can
you talk about what it was like when you
visited and what kinds of potatoes you
saw it does blow the mind when you walk
into a market in Peru and you see many
of these native potatoes they are all
sorts of colors they are all sorts of
shapes they have different tastes and
textures it's like an heirloom potato
it's not grown by big farmers they are
standard potatoes they're consistent the
technical term is a land race compared
to a farmer in the in the United States
who will grow one type of potato four
hectares a potato farmer a small-scale
potato farmer in the Andes will be
growing dozens sometimes more than a
hundred different kinds of potato all
together it's dynamic and diverse way of
keeping a real range of genetic
diversity alive how our farmers and
agriculturalists and researchers taking
advantage of all of that diversity are
they taking some of these amazing purple
potatoes and bringing them into a lab
and then breeding them with the russet
and trying to get some of that
resilience or other kind of special
qualities into what's being a standard
potato for a long time you might want to
take a potato that's grown in the
developing world and cross it with a
land race that's high in zinc or iron oh
and then you could have a more
nutritious potato or you might want to
take potato that can survive a frost or
in an entirely different situation you
might want to take a potato
that can grow well in salty soil to
expand where you're producing potatoes
some of these traits are found in land
races many more of these traits are
found in the wild relatives potato are
you saying there's potato hunters
looking for wild potatoes and bringing
them back and figuring out what their
traits are the thing about domesticating
a plant is that you take something you
like a tuber or a fruit thousands of
years ago rights people saw things they
liked and they selected for those traits
so now we have big potatoes sweet fruit
and you're doing it from a wild species
right just like the dog was domesticated
from the wolf the potato was
domesticated from not a wolf but right
something that was very good at
surviving in the wild so the wild
relatives potatoes right you might not
like to eat their tubers because they're
bitter and small but those plants might
do really well surviving against the
pathogen that cost late blight for
example or in in a hot climate it sounds
like we have a good source of diversity
maybe some sources of resilience is
there any plan in place to speed up the
process of introducing those traits we
can't do it you know gene editing isn't
going to work so well because there are
complex traits you might have a lot of
different genes involved is there any
way to go faster to do that to simplify
the potato for breeding you need to use
potatoes that have only two copies of
chromosomes just like corn rather than
four that still functions a sub
functional potato that can grow it and
and reproduce yes potatoes can do fine
with two copies of their chromosomes
then you make them more genetically
uniform in order to have these what are
called elite breeding lines you never
plant these potatoes but you use them to
create potatoes that have great
qualities and then those potatoes are
planted we should talk about the other
impetus for improving the potato the way
it handles the way it grow is how
efficient it is a crop it's because so
many more people are eating the potato
now than they were 50 years ago can you
talk about the spread of the potato into
the cuisines of all these different
places in the world I was really
surprised and maybe I shouldn't have
been to learn what the number one grower
of potatoes in the world is should I
guess China yeah you're right but only
because you said I'd be surprised it
grows twice as many potatoes as India
and India is the second largest grower
and both those countries for the last
five decades they have been growing more
and more potatoes
whereas Ireland Poland a lot of these
northern European countries they're
growing fewer and fewer too many ideas
about why this change happened they're
really versatile and useful you can grow
in China you can grow a potato in
between your rice crops on the same
field you've added a new crop and new
production and not taken away from
anything else if you grow potatoes
you're getting more calories per acre
than if you grow wheat they're becoming
more and more important for food
security and they're delicious and
they're really good yeah I had no idea
that potato was so complicated
genetically or that it was so Hardy but
then it also has weird issues with night
heat it's just really interesting and
then there's so much diversity
maintained in South America
thanks so much Eric I'm gonna have to
keep my eye on potatoes in the future
too talking acerra Eric stalks Ted is a
staff writer for science you can find a
link to the article we discussed at
science magnet or slash podcast
stay tuned for Megan Cantwell's
interview with staff writer Bob Service
on a pill that delivers medicine by
injecting it into the lining of the
stomach
[Music]
this week's episode is brought to you in
part by Kiwi Co Q eco creates supercool
hands-on projects for kids that make
learning about steam fun with a Q eco
subscription each month the kid in your
life be it your own kid your neighbors
kids nieces nephews random kid on the
street will receive a fun engaging new
project which will help develop their
creativity and confidence there are
seven types of crates to choose from
we've got the tadpole crate for infants
the Koala crate to engage naturally
curious preschoolers like mine all the
way up to the Eureka crate for anyone
over 14 which includes most of our
listeners and also myself basically a
Kiwi COEs mission is to empower kids not
just to make a project but to make a
difference every crate includes the
supplies needed for that month's project
you don't need to go to the store and
pick up anything it's all in there and
you've got detailed easy-to-follow
instructions and an educational magazine
to learn more about that crates themed
Kiwi Co is offering a science magazine
podcast listeners the chance to try them
for free to redeem this offer and learn
more visit kiwi cocom slash magazine
[Music]
ever since the introduction of insulin
shots there's been an effort to create
an oral formulation but the passage from
your mouth to your gut is a treacherous
journey acids and thick mucus can all
spell trouble for a fragile molecule
like insulin I'm here with Bob service a
staff writer at science to talk about
what a pill form of insulin could look
like in the future hey Bob
hey Megan what are the challenges to
making a pill form of insulin there's a
couple of them the first thing our
intestinal system has three lines of
Defense's and so first it has very
highly acidic stomach acids that will
cause proteins to unravel or denature
and then once that happens there are set
of enzymes in our stomachs that will
then chop those proteins up basically
our digestive system sees large proteins
like insulin or other kinds of drug
molecules as food and it tries to break
them down and it does you mentioned in
your introduction there's this thick
mucus layer and that basically is
another way that the stomach and small
intestine holds any molecules at arm's
length preventing them from trying to
get through the stomach lining or the
intestinal lining and then if they do
happen to even run that gauntlet that
far the cells of the small intestine are
tightly packed together which makes it
really really hard for anything to get
through what did previous pill
formulations of insulin look like well
there's been lots of different attempts
and and not just with insulin but with
many kinds of molecules in one of the
ways they try to do this or with other
chemical components that they add to
them these are called permeation
enhancers and basically they cause the
cells and the intestinal lining to
separate a little bit and allow those
biologics then to wiggle in but they
tend not to be very effective for
anything as large as insulin they work
better on very small proteins called
peptides now I think what we're seeing
is a couple of different lines of
research one is building on these
permeation enhancers and they're doing a
couple of things
they add other components to them to
hide the molecules hide these large
biologics from the stomach acids first
then they also have compounds in them
designed to prevent the proteases from
chopping proteins up that combination is
one where researchers are trying to put
all those pieces together to protect
their biological molecules then they're
also taking this more engineering
approach so but there's a paper out
today in science that describes a small
pill that is engineered to deploy a very
tiny micro needle once it's in the right
position in the stomach and so then what
that does is it just injects insulin in
this case directly across that barrier
layer and into the bloodstream and
they've shown that it can work as well
as a subcutaneous injection how does the
release mechanism in that pill work yeah
so it's pretty cool so what they do is
they've designed a little hollow pill
that it sort of looks like an acorn
without the cap but it's got that curved
highly curved top right so no matter how
it lands when it hits the bottom of the
stomach it writes itself it Orient's
itself so that the flat end is pressing
up against the stomach lining and then
the moist environment of the stomach
corrodes over a few minutes a cap that
is holding a spring a loaded spring in
place inside the capsule so once that
covered dissolves enough that spring
pops out and injects the insulin across
the stomach lining all of the injector
is pretty small are there any health
risks from repeatedly puncturing the
lining of the stomach sure that's gonna
be an important thing that they're gonna
have to track very carefully because
that you know frankly that's the problem
with permeation enhancers as well I mean
you don't want anything causing any kind
of lasting damage that's going to allow
bacteria to get in there into the
bloodstream the researchers who did the
work on the pill injector they studied
rats and pigs over time they gave them
daily injections and they didn't see any
problems with it but this of course will
have to be followed up with much
longer-term health studies and animals
even before people as I'm not sure if
they would be able to know this from the
animal models that they tested on but
can you actually feel when the injector
is in the stomach lining they don't know
yeah because the animals couldn't tell
them those parts of our body don't have
a lot of pain
nerve endings and so there is another
company that is pursuing a related
strategy it's actually quite similar
with these pills with an injector it's a
bit different of a mechanism it doesn't
have a spring-loaded rather what happens
is once it reaches the small intestine
the pH in that environment causes a
chemical reaction that produces carbon
dioxide it's sort of like analysis
alka-seltzer medication or something
like that where did the bubbles form in
that this blows up a little balloon and
that has a needle on it and that pushes
the needle into the lining of the small
intestine
they're called Rani therapeutics they're
out of San Jose California they've done
just in a very initial study safety
study with people in which they had
unloaded capsules so with no drug in
them or no no injector but they did have
the balloon and people didn't even
notice it they couldn't even tell so
that's a good first step but obviously
they have a long way to go this company
the pill is deploying in the small
intestine is there any advantage to
deploying in the stomach lining versus a
small intestine that will have to be
seen over time I mean folks are gonna
have to research that very carefully one
argument is is that if you're deploying
in the stomach you know that a pill can
pass through your mouth and esophagus
into your stomach within seconds and so
the timing is very clear about how long
after that that medicine will start to
be injected and essentially deployed
whereas things can take a much more
variable amount of time to go from the
stomach to the small intestine so I
think that was the thinking behind it
but you know companies who try to
deliver things biologics to the small
intestine say they're getting good
reproducible results in animals anyway
so they don't see that as a problem okay
and do both of these pills show the same
efficiency in lowering blood sugar
levels as if you were to give yourself
an injection they do but again these are
with animals so this will have to be
studied in people and
in terms of for insulin as I understand
it diabetics who take insulin will take
a couple of different kinds so there's
the kind where what we normally think
about is a diabetic around a meal we'll
inject insulin to modulate their blood
sugar levels but they also in many cases
will take a once-daily
injection and that's called basal
insulin in order to just provide a
baseline amount of the the compound and
so that's what this would be to replace
at least initially it wouldn't be to
replace the insulin you would take with
a meal both of these technologies are
pretty similar in that their injector
pills but are there any other approaches
to an oral formulation being explored
right now right so there are these sort
of souped-up permeation enhancers we
talked about before
one of them that just came out last year
a group at Harvard has made this liquid
that goes in a capsule with the insulin
and in this case the liquid is sort of
the consistency of honey so once it
reaches the small intestines the capsule
dissolves and that honey like substance
then kind of gloms on to the lining of
the small intestine and then works to
encourage the insulin to get through
well all these oral formulations are in
different stages of development right
now but when do you think we may be able
to see some of these on the market it's
likely still going to be years the first
rule of any kind of medicine is first do
no harm so we already know that we have
very good delivery systems that use
needles and injections and those work
well and those protect the lives of
hundreds of millions of people so
whatever comes next has to be shown to
be as safe as those are so and all those
types of medicines will face rigorous
safety studies once those do pass
however it could spread quite rapidly
because all the companies that are
looking at these different kinds of
formulations or engineered devices are
designing them to work with medicines
are already approved so if the delivery
mechanisms can be shown to be safe well
then it's conceivable that a number of
different kinds of compounds could be
delivered this way and that
set of progress could happen very
quickly what is the motivation behind
creating these oral formulations why is
it important to have a pill version of
insulin or any of these other biologics
with any medicine the most important
thing is to be able to take the medicine
when it's needed as often as it's needed
and so for something like insulin you
want very high compliance anytime you
have an injectable medication versus an
oral medication oral medications always
have higher compliance because a lot of
people don't like needles for obvious
reasons so that's number one there's
also a definitely a motivation for the
companies because or the company's
developing these technologies because
then they could potentially sell they
would have massive markets because as I
said before depends on the year but
seven or eight of the top ten selling
drugs in the US are biologics and so
these are huge massive markets and so
there's a lot of money to be made as
well so there's both a lot of health and
safety reasons but a lot of commercial
reasons as well all right thank you so
much Bob oh you're welcome Megan anytime
bob service is a staff writer at science
you can find a link to his piece at
science magic slash podcasts and that
concludes this edition of the science
podcast if you have any comments or
suggestions for the show write to us at
science podcast at AAA SOR G and we're
still looking for a book reviewer so if
you have radio experience which means
you can record yourself and edit
yourself and you have science background
please do get in touch we've gotten lots
of really nice letters from people
saying I love the podcast I love the
science books but I don't really know
how to edit and it's just we need
someone to help edit with that you can
subscribe to the show anywhere you get
your podcast or you can listen on the
science website that's science mag org
slash podcasts to place an ad on the
podcast contact mid-roll comm the show
was produced by Sarah crispy and Megan
Cantwell and edited by Potter G Jeffery
cook compose the music on behalf of
science magazine and his publisher
triple-a s thanks for joining us